[Music]
all right good afternoon everybody
thanks for thanks for having me here my
name is Jorden sigani engineering
director on Google bigquery I was one of
the first engineers on bigquery when we
sort of were just still trying to figure
out what to build and I've sort of been
riding the the big query wave for the
last the last seven years and it's been
it's been pretty exciting I'll be joined
by Lloyd tab the the CTO of liquor I'll
tell you a little bit more about liquor
when we get to to his his part but in my
opinion the the best the best
innovations come from when you when you
break constraints when you have a wall
that seemed insurmountable so
insurmountable that people sort of
forgot it was there and then all of a
sudden that wall is gone and all of a
sudden then you can do all of these
creative creative things with it
here's an example how many people had a
phone that looks something like this
anybody old enough yeah we have we have
plenty so so much engineering energy
went into trying to figure out what's to
do with a damn keypad and how to you
know all kinds of clever sliding things
and and they didn't pay any attention to
the screen and then you know somebody
okay probably Apple came up with a great
idea of of what if we didn't even have a
keypad and I think those are kind of the
most exciting things where it's like all
of a sudden this constraint the keyboard
was gone and and the smart phones really
took off after that so what's the big
constraint in databases well the big
constraint in databases is the table
scan and you don't have to take take
that from me you take that from the
Oracle who's invested more engineering
energy in in building fast databases
than probably anybody and they says you
know basically table scans or a
nightmare
so what if you can we can remove that
constraint what if we can just make
table scans fast and so I'm gonna start
into a little bit of like how databases
work to sort of build up into how how we
can make table scans fast up so the the
primary data structure
or for databases of bee tree or B+ tree
and it effectively works by building a
tree of your data so this this select
query that's doing a filter between
these two two boundaries filter on this
key you know we're able to to to fetch
that data doing only five lookup because
we only have to read these five blocks
nicely chances are the top part of the
tree is gonna be cached so it might only
be two blocks the problem is what if you
want to run a query that you don't have
the you're not you can't filter
conveniently on the key well you have to
read the whole the whole thing and that
takes that takes a long time um so one
way that people have tried to scale
databases is they scale it out by
basically taking taking a database and
running it sort of in multiple nodes and
then with some lightweight coordination
on top I won't mention any competitors
but this is what a lot of people do and
there's a couple of problems with this
one is that the you're limited to the
storage that's attached to that node so
it's hard to hard to scale that up and
the other one is I mean first of all
also like the the coordination effort
gets really difficult in another session
concurrently where people are talking
about bigquery geospatial and advances
that were that we're launching today and
one of things that does is it does you
can do a cross join that says you know
show me the points from this table that
are near the points from this table in a
in an architecture like this that's
super difficult because you have to send
all of this data between between these
nodes so the network bandwidth becomes a
big constraint so what did the what are
the folks at Google do you know the
Dremel paper came out 2010 and Jarmo
been around for several years several
years before then but effectively the
way they they approach scaling was we're
just gonna scale everything out super
wide so each one of these sort of boxes
is a separate machine now or as a
separate task or a separate container
running in running in Borg and we're
gonna make everything a table scan
because we have we have our fast
distributed file system which is which
is Colossus so you can read from
hundreds of thousands of disks
we can read on a hundred thousand cores
and we can make make this table scan
fast so we've been able to remove a
bunch of database design constraints
there's the i/o constraints you know
disks are slow if you read from a small
number of disks that's going to be
that's gonna be painful attached storage
you can only you know deal with the
stores that's on that machine CPUs
aren't getting faster more law Moore's
Law is sort of ended for for CPU speeds
and there's also as I mentioned the
network coordination bottleneck so how
does big query do it big query slash
Dremel because Dremel is the query
engine that powers big query well it's
gonna read from lots and lots of disks
in parallel we have the separation of
storage and compute so you don't have
any scaling scaling bottlenecks as you
know actually Lloyd and I were chatting
yesterday he says you can't fill it up
he says that not me I know how many
disks we have so and we can use
thousands of CPUs in parallel and we can
use our you know Google's very fast
Jupiter infrastructure so the general
architecture as when we released it sort
of looks looks similar to that tree this
is this is a diagram from the from the
original Dremel paper but one of the
things we CERN soon learned when we when
we release bigquery is the log scanning
is not data warehousing people you know
if they're gonna remove their analysis
onto on to bigquery we have to be good
at data warehousing so we made a big bet
on on dynamic query planning and an
optimization and one of the what this
means is is we will dynamically change
the query plan depending on on how that
query query runs so that we can run it
in a optimal distributed fashion so 2018
this is you know this is sort of a
stylized version of what the the current
architecture is it's no longer a fixed
tree you know basically every there's
number of stages each stage goes through
a shuffle which is a fast in-memory
shuffle and finally have the reduce at
the at the end and we can you know
dynamically change how many shards were
using we could Emily dynamically change
the you know whether we want to do a
broadcast or a hash join we can
dynamically change how many stages if
we're running so bigquery is a data
warehouse we're I'm gonna try to
convince you that bigquery has item I
think a lot of other talks at next have
have have also talked about big queries
the data warehouse and I'm gonna go
through some of the myths and and how we
have how we've overcome them or how
those are not actually true so one of
the myths is you know I think that's
this is even in some of our some of our
documentation that says you know you
should do normalize your data when when
you're using bigquery and now if you're
if you're in an enterprise data
warehousing situation and you want to
move your Tara data or you want to move
whatever your existing system is into
into bigquery you're like well I don't
want to change my schema I just want my
old queries to run so we understand that
and so one of the things we've been
working on because you know for
enterprise data warehousing is you need
joints to work fast and so this is sort
of how we've done over the this is the
TPC eh benchmark TPO with 10 terabytes
over the last 18 months and so we've
increased performance and the Geo mean
so this isn't we're not cherry-picking
individual individual queries to run
here but you know we've we've gotten 5 X
5 X faster across the board
this is TPC DS which is another another
common data warehousing benchmark that
is also increased by by 5 X and I'm show
you so that last little bit at the end
that little that dive down is a
performance improvement that you know we
just sort of we rolled out this week so
can we switch over the demo please so
this is the TPC eds benchmark and this
is sort of using kind of the old old
system and I had this run and we can see
that this ran it ran over 675 gigabytes
and it took a minute and 10 seconds I'm
not gonna you know make you wait for a
minute and 10 seconds while that runs
but I will switch over to the new
version the new version is exactly the
same query that's TPC T BCS query 6 and
we can run this we can run this now and
it's
the query is exactly the same the only
difference is it's it's running against
sort of the the clustered version of the
tables and I'll describe clustering in
in a couple of couple of minutes there
we go so thirteen point three seconds
versus so there's a 5 X 5 X improvement
and this is just sort of the kind of
thing that you know we roll out on a on
a Thursday because because it's because
it's ready can we switch back please can
we switch back to the slides please okay
so you know now sort of we're
advertising or best practice is don't
denormalize if you don't if you don't
need to if your schema is more natural
in in the de normalized state then by
all means do you normalize it or if the
queries are simpler or if you're doing
joins against a large large dimension
table a large dimension table so let's
say you have a star schema and you know
if your fact table and then your your
other table is fairly large you might
consider denormalizing
but but but that's also something we're
working on and we're working on the
reason I have an asterisk by large is
because is because actually what large
means is it should be increasing over
time and as I mentioned joins and be
getting faster and they will continue to
get faster we've got a bunch of things
on our roadmap that hopefully will gonna
we're going to continue to to to improve
things so I was chatting with Lloyd my
co-presenter here a couple a couple
months ago and he said to me I love
bigquery but you guys need to improve
partitioning and we're like yeah yeah we
know he actually didn't use as didn't
say it as nicely as that but this is the
this is he approved this version of the
slide so the version of partitioning
that we've had we've had for a long time
is ingestion based partitioning in it
how do I just want to go through how
this works so that I can show what we're
doing differently so bigquery is a
columnar store has a column store so
when you when you run to select you only
only have to read the we only charge you
for the the columns that you that you
read so in old old
query we kind of read down the columns
but partitioning actually lets us do a
slice across so you know if you have a
partition filter you know we're using
this sort of magical pseudo column
that's based on based on ingestion time
but it does let you you know select only
those only those bits and and and only
have to pay for for reading the data
that's that's in that sort of that's
intersection and and only have two so
it's not just a cost but it's also a
performance improvement but so just
recently we made column based
partitioning generally available column
based partitioning means you don't have
to use this special pseudo column this
means you can use you can use a column
in your in your table and that's your
partitioning column and queries on that
will to sort of naturally naturally
filter but so you know that's that's
great that's been in the process for a
while that's not really you know gonna
move the needle for the most part but
today we're not saying clustering and
clustering I think is is really pretty
cool
and that takes partitioning sort of way
beyond how it had worked before I'm
going to just when you have a table
clusters you have your your partition
key but then you also have your
clustering key and you know what a lot
of people like to use is like a user ID
or a customer ID and big query will
actually store this in in sorted format
SOR te D not SOR D ID so when you filter
based on that you only have to read the
you know we can read a very very small
amount so to give you two sort of an
example how this works so of course we
apply the partition filter then we apply
the cluster filter and we all have to
read a very very small sliver of that of
that table so queries are going to be
not only faster but they're going to be
be less expensive so clustering works
with a high cardinality generally you
use it when you have a high cardinality
field you only pay for scanning blocks
that that matched your cluster key it's
going to be faster and it's gonna be
easier to manage because we have a lot
of people that are kind of manually
sharding they're you know one table per
customer now
can put that in one in one table and
just to do a filter and it's sort of
more natural data management such of the
demo please so I'm just gonna start this
so last year maybe it's two years ago at
at at cloud next I ran this this query
over this giant petabyte table that we
had this petabyte table is is a
simulated retail schema and and we can
see kind of what is is in this table
it's got it's got sales and then it you
can join out two to two products and so
I'm doing a select star which you rarely
do in bigquery because it reads all the
columns and this is doing a filter by
filter by key so this is the the
clustering key now one of the things
that I didn't show last time was I
didn't show how much this query costs
because when I ran it two years ago this
was actually a five thousand dollar
query you know bigquery bigquery is fast
and it scales but like but you pay for
that so you know we prefer let's say
well you can scale it can't scale it to
this and and you know many people who
have this this size table would be using
you know fixed price reservations so
they they wouldn't they wouldn't have to
pay per query but if you're gonna pay
sort of retail prices that's how much it
would cost and when I ran this when I
ran this two years ago it took two
hundred and two hundred and seventy
seconds so I think it was I think it was
almost almost five minutes so we've made
some made some performance improvements
since then and usually this takes well
we'll see how long this takes it's gonna
take a couple more seconds I'm gonna
switch to the switch to the next one and
and come back to it so you know as I was
that was just a scan filter query and as
I promised you bigquery is not just good
at you know log scanning bigquery is
also good at doing joins and so actually
last year one of the things that I did
was I showed I showed how to do query
optimization and one of the things that
I showed was it optimism
was okay if you're joining if your
filter is on the wrong side of the joint
key then or the joint constraint then
your query is gonna be really your query
can be really slow so this is just
showing that a not only have we sort of
we fixed that by being able to push the
constraints through through the query
but also you know now we can do let's
see this was so it's query over the over
the petabyte table three and a half
seconds we're actually doing a real join
against against a real real table all
right now let's jump back to to this
query which finished in in just under
two minutes so we're about twice as fast
as we were two years ago you know things
get things get faster but one of the
cool things is if you look at how much
data we processed it's half a gigabyte
so this is what you pay for so we've
gone from five thousand dollars to this
is about a tenth of a penny so this is
what like four orders of magnitude five
orders of magnitude price improvement
[Applause]
and back to the slides please so in case
you're wondering when to use
partitioning and when to use clustering
so they are they are different you know
if you have a database background people
tend to be familiar with these with
these terms if not it may be a little
bit a little bit confusing partitioning
is generally when you have a small
number of distinct distinct values you
know less than ten thousand is is our
maximum for partitioning right now
clustering can be any any cardinality
you can have you know millions or
billions of different different values
in bigquery you know the dry run pricing
for partitioning is exact
so before you run the query will tell
you exactly how much it call how much
it's going to cost for cluster tables
we're gonna we're gonna tell you the
maximum it could cost and if you have a
clustering filter it could be it could
be a lot less that's sort of what you as
sort of what you what's you give up and
so the query pricing is is exact for
partitioning its best effort for
clustering so if you're writing a lot to
your your your table we may not have
sorted it completely and so we're gonna
charge based on whatever we have to to
end up reading there is a small
performance head for overhead for
clustered tables per per partition that
you're scanning my clustering doesn't
doesn't suffer from any of that but only
other partitioning can be you know you
can do data management like it's like
it's a table you can have expiration
times on your on your clusters whereas
sorry on your partitions we're on
clustering you have to use use DML okay
so I want to address some other other
myths about about big queries so one
thing people will say is well big query
can't do row and column level security
so we do it in a slightly different way
we use we you can use authorized views
and so this has been available for a
long time but I kind of want to describe
it because I think it's underutilized so
first step you can create a view of the
data that you want to share and I could
filter out the rows and columns you
don't want to use or you don't want
somebody to see and then you add the out
of view of add that view to the Akal of
the source data set now what this does
is it lets the person who owns that data
set see exactly who has access so we're
not doing kind of delegated
authorization or anything
and you don't have to worry about if the
person who created that then leaves the
company you know you can audit you can
actually see what's on that Akal so just
to show kind of how this works on a
typical table let's say you have the you
know a phone number you know which has
PII and you don't want people to see it
and maybe you have some sort of like
special rows that you also want to keep
wants to keep private so you just create
a view definition that let's say it
filters out the the rows you don't want
to show and you know hashes the the
phone number and so the person so by
default you can only you can only see
this view if you if you have access to
the underlying data but so the next
thing you do is you can add to the the
data set you can say allow allowed this
view access to this table and then you
can share access to that that view so
one of the things we like to talk about
in bigquery is just how easy it is to
share your data and we see this as a
positive
Loida will also describe a little bit
about that but you know I was talking to
somebody at a at a briefing in Texas and
he's like well you know easy data
sharing that sounds like a bug and not a
feature that means you somebody can
share it with somebody that I don't want
it to be shared with so Google virtual
private cloud is is something that's in
in beta and that's gonna allow you to
prevent and so we could have kind of
implemented something like this just for
bigquery but this is actually sort of an
implemented across Google's cloud using
kind of standardized mechanisms so
you'll be able to prevent anybody from
sharing your bigquery data outside of
your organization you'll be able to
define which services can be used like
so maybe you can you know you can't
export it to to GCS it allows you to cut
it to to control the the routes of data
exfiltration and and cut it off
completely or cut it off to certain
people or certain certain buckets I mean
you can also say that you know this can
only be accessed from your
organization's IP IP range and so with
like the virtual virtual cluster you
know you can have stuff in your in your
compute engine instances that that look
like you're there from your
organization's IP range and so those
will just magically work whereas some
you know random hacker is not going to
not going to be able to access another
thing that people people tend to want is
they want to be able to control their
own encryption keys so bigquery has a
generally available feature they've had
we have since since February that allows
you to to manage your own encryption
keys and so this sort of reduces the the
kind of debug ability from from the
bigquery side like you know we can't go
in and figure out what went wrong with
the query as easily without getting
explicit explicit approval but and also
it allows you to basically just be on in
control of how encryption is being
applied and so this is sort of how you
know how the encryption works and the
decrypts the final decryption actually
happens all the way down on the storage
layer and you're the key material is
actually has never never flows through
the the bigquery servers nor does the
the the encryption or decryption
happened there so I also want to so you
know with gdpr and with other you know
requirements people want to have clean
ways to manage their personally
identifiable information and their PII
data and so I want to share a design
pattern that one of our customers uses
that uses encryption to to to control
who has access to to PII and actually
actually remove it so if you know for
sort of if somebody wants to be
forgotten so let's say you have a table
with PII this is sort of the basic basic
table the the phone number column is PII
so you can encrypt that with with a key
you can equip that with a key per row or
per user ID you have a separate table
that has the keys and they'd match up
with each with each user ID so when you
read that you can you can run an aes
decryption which is the new functions
that we have to to decrypt the data and
the nice thing about this is you can
share this table with anybody you want
you can you can they can copy that table
you don't have to necessarily chase it
down but they can't actually read the
PII in it unless they have access to
this underlying underlying keys table
and then if you you know for the right
to be forgotten or you know you want to
get rid of that user you know crypto
delete as as simple as just doing a DML
delete from the from that that Keys
table so you don't have to go back and
figure out all the places where that PII
went it just I can out no longer be
accessed another myth that is that you
know people people are worried that
bigquery makes it makes it easy to run
up run up a big a big bill
we now have self-service cost control so
I one more demo if you don't mind
switching over thank you and so I just
want to show how this works this is the
the Google Cloud console you can get
here from where'd it go I am an admin
and quotas filter by bigquery API and
you can change the the allowable if I
can click on this no you change the
allowable usage per day you can see edit
quotas sorry this is Lloyd's laptop he
doesn't have he doesn't have permission
but had Lloyd did which I guess is a
good thing we don't want him to change
our change like quotas but had we had
permission we could just say edit quotas
here for the the bigquery API the query
usage per day and that gets implied
immediately so that's across your
project there's also a per user one that
you can that you can say so if you want
to say you know each user should only be
able to process 10 terabytes a day you
can set that you can set that here that
one doesn't get applied immediately
there's there's a little bit of a delay
but at least there's sort of a
self-service ways that you can you can
manage that back to the slides please
something else that sort of a myth is
that bigquery doesn't allow enough DML
updates we do have batch DML operations
so often a people are used to do sort of
individual you know deletes you can
delete from an array you can delete you
know based on another based on a filter
you can delete based on
join from another table but there's
another really cool thing that's that's
in beta right now
is the sequel merge statement and I
wasn't aware of the sequel merge
statement it's actually pretty pretty
slick pretty slick things I want to go
through how this works a little bit so
let's say we have a customers table and
let's say we have another table that has
our has our updates and we want to sort
of apply those updates to the to the
customers table so the first thing we do
is we create we start start our merge
statement and we say we're going to
merge and we're gonna kind of match
those up using using the user ID and you
can use like you know complex complex
conditions here so then we match those
you can then you can then define match
conditions so if there is a match
between the two so between the user ID
on one side and the user ID on the other
side and you can even make those
conditions arbitrarily complex you can
say also if the table on the left is not
locked and we can do something and the
thing we want to do is update update it
to be the thing that's on the right so
fancy animation we've see we've updated
that that row but you can do more with a
single a single statement you can also
say well when if there's not a match
which means that if there's not
something in the left table if there's
something in the right table that's not
in the left you can in this case we'll
say well we're gonna we're gonna insert
that into into the the left-hand table
but wait there's more
we could even say would not match by
source which means if something's in the
left table but not on the right table we
can apply complex conditions as well we
can just say you know in this case we're
just saying saying delete but this last
allows you to do sort of really complex
like you know read insert update delete
all in a single all in a single
statement all right so I've tried to
convince you that bigquery is a great
place to do to do data warehousing but I
think you know one of the things that I
showed with the the reason that I had
that the initial kind of removing
removing constraints discussion was I
think bigquery can be more is more than
just than just the data warehouse and
you know of course I'm biased I've been
working on bigquery for seven years and
Google pays
to say nice things about about bigquery
so Lloyd's gonna come up and talk about
sort of beyond just normal data
warehousing and the kinds of things that
that that he's been able to do and so
Lloyd is the inventor of looker he is a
big kind of bigquery aficionado he's
been able to push bigquery really
further than you know almost anybody
that I've seen so I think there's not
anybody better to show what else you can
do with bigquery
thanks Lloyd thanks so as as Jordan says
I'm a bit of a geek so I'm not much of a
speaker so I apologize in advance I'm
gonna talk I'm gonna frame that the what
you can do with bigquery first you know
I've been trying to think about how to
explain this for a long time since I
actually starting looker and I still
never got it's it's never been perfect
so this is a new way of describing it
that I'm gonna try on you guys and see
if it makes any sense in the in the in
the traditional reporting world I think
I think of that world as 2d data and 2d
information and and those that that
answers questions about what happened so
a traditional 2d thing might be
something like the New York Times the
New York Times is vetted every day the
it's a digest of the best of it most of
the things that happen then that day you
know that the information is accurate
you can bank on the the veracity of the
information and it and it's important a
textbook is another example of 2d a 2d
report and for most part in enterprise
2d reporting is what you run your
business on the SEC is very you if
you're if you build a report and it goes
to the SEC you've you very much care
about the accuracy event there's another
kind of information though that's
happened since the dawn of the Internet
and I was lucky enough to be around at
the beginning and and that that
experience that 3d information is
something like say Google where you can
go ask a question and do some research
about a subject so the 2d information
say here's an example of you suppose
you're reading the New York Times and
you see a new competitor
and you read about the company well if
you're interested in that you know that
it exists but there's not a lot more
that you can do with it about with that
piece of information you if and
pre-internet you'd run down to the to
the library and look for other
periodicals about it and see or call
people and see if you could find some
information about it but in the post
Internet world you go to Google and you
type in the company name and you look
and LinkedIn and you see how many
employees they have and you might look
on CrunchBase and see who the investors
are and who the principal's in it and
you might look on a glass door to see
whether or not the employees like
working there and what's going so there
they're there other ways of doing
research about about something to get a
better picture to get more perspective
so 2d is flat and accurate and perfect
and super important because you can't
run your business without that and most
of the time we think of data we think of
it in that way but there's another way
of thinking about data which is the
investigative way and it really hasn't
really in these new tools like bigquery
allow that to happen and what's so
what's important in that is that you
have a pretty comprehensive source of
information so like the web there's lots
and lots of ways to look at it and to
dig at it and because we because of
things like these new data works just
like bigquery
you can put all the data in one place
and then do and bigquery and things like
bigquery a looker can actually do the
research to find out information about
that and so the 2d information answers
what happened and the 3d is about
Diagnostics about why it happened right
and there have been you can extract data
and with small datasets to try to look
at why something happened so people have
been interested in that for a while but
but really to get a holistic picture you
need the whole dataset so that's my
that's what I think that you should be
thinking about trying to build out a big
query and so I'm gonna give an example
of 3d data experience one of our looker
early customers was a hotel aggregator
and there was a marketing person and
they had a 2d report which was they were
looking at at their user base and they
were trying to figure out referrals
because cost of acquisition for the for
this business was super-important right
they in order to be able to drive
business they got to drive the cost of
customer acquisition down so that they
could then and get and get them to stay
and to spend more on the plan
from overtime so they had a little
rapport it was just a grid and on the
coat one corner it was how many bookings
they had going across and how many
referrals they had going down and in the
lower left hand the lower I didn't left
left-hand corner there was a number and
it was big so these were people who had
never ordered but referred a lot they
had of people who had ordered a lot and
referred a lot that would that was that
but it would surprise them was the
number of people who had had ordered who
never ordered but referred and they were
like we were getting game what's going
on and in a 2d world you're kind of done
that's it I got that I got to go back to
the data team to get it but in a 3d
world they can click on it which
isolates the data basically would
isolate it to the to the both of those
constraints or never ordered and
referred a lot and they could then look
at the detail
so it's isolation and drilling into the
detail and then they got a list of email
addresses and they said well they
weren't an engineer like me so they were
marketers so they were not afraid of
actually emailing them and saying who
are you and why are you doing this and
they got and it came back I'm a taxi
driver I'm an airline stewardess I'm a
bartender I'm someone who gets asked the
question where should I stay tonight
right and that changed their business
right that that ability to actually walk
around and drill into the data it's
actually going from the to from the 2d
perspective through the 3d perspective
gave them a chance to to see more data
to understand why that was happening
I'll give you another example before so
looker I've been working looking for six
years but I've been working I've been at
CTO for a bunch at a bunch of companies
and one of the companies I was at was a
I was the CTO of an online crowdsource
call center with 30,000 home-based
operators and my job was to make it so
that everybody in the company could see
data so I built some special purpose
tools and we have this measure that we
use called a chump who knows what a chop
is see a cup is a phone call where the
caller hang up hung up before it came to
an operator right and so
how you at so an operational measure
that we picked was the number of chops
over the number of total Capone calls
what percentage of calls were chops and
then we would look at this over time and
in the middle of the day we saw a big
spike and I said there was a bunch of
chumps in an hour period so we isolated
it so we were like well why don't why
are their chops and so that the the to D
report said there was a problem but the
three d but we wanted to do some
analysis so the way that you start to do
analysis is you isolate it to that you
filter on the range that's that's there
and you start to dimensionalize it by
different things you can dimensionalize
it by operator well was there one
operator who wasn't picking up it was we
were outing to them and they weren't
picking up now that wasn't the problem
was it one program that we had a whole
bunch of phone calls for a particular
program then we were answering calls for
no that wasn't the problem
well let's isolate it by telephony
switch oh look this switch is broken
right and so by dimensionalizing the
data and and walking around the data you
can actually see it and and so these are
the kinds of things you can build out of
a modern data warehouse that and and I
plant a data platform like looker that's
not possible before so traditional data
warehousing is all about the accurate
report right it's all about it's all
about getting the data right so in order
to do this what you do is that you vet
the data on the way in so the the the
the the traditional way of putting data
into a data warehouse is that it's small
and it's relatively small the data
warehouse is expensive storage is
expensive so what you do is you you you
you take your transactional systems and
you bet it and you compress it and you
put it into the database and you know
that the data is accurate so that once
it lands in the warehouse right the
whole idea is get it in there it's right
nothing no the data team is working as
the ETL team they're the person that
makes sure that it's there right and the
new data warehousing model you land the
data in the warehouse and then you build
models on top of that and you code on
top of that to make so that so that you
can draw more together so you have
access to all of the detail and you
build what we we say that you build a
real a a model against that data so that
so that you know that it's accurate and
and when you pull it out when you pull
the data out it comes through code as
opposed to coming through
way they were in and so we've been
working together with bigquery for quite
some time and we've together we make
this great platform that you can use to
to do this 3d experience in data I'm
gonna they invited me up here because I
I do wild things with bigquery I'm gonna
show you a couple of cool a couple cool
things one thing that that bigquery is
so I end up looking works against almost
every kind of database there is but I
really love big queries sequel because
it is amazing about what it's amazing
how they've implemented it and what's
different about them is their arrays
structures the UDF's and the nesting as
well as the ability to handle just
astronomical astronomical amounts of
data but the structures in the UDF's and
the nesting allow you to build stuff
that that that you can't possibly build
in a traditional data warehouse and it
all comes down to a piece of
technologies that are razor Struck's are
really sub tables on a single row of
data who is anybody here played with the
arrays instructs in bigquery oh cool and
UDF's
cool it's super powerful so I'm actually
I'm going to do I'm gonna do a demo in a
little bit but everything comes down to
the fact that you I'll keep repeating
this slides gonna appear a couple of
times it's it's really important to
recognize that in a table a repeated
record is really just a is really just a
in bigquery of structure and an array of
structs and you can treat that as if it
were a table that there there are
basically three kinds of UDF's and big
queries the obvious one is the scale or
EDF you can pass and you can pass the
string and parse something out of a
string in a UDF and you can do that in
JavaScript or you can do that in sequel
but what's not necessarily obvious is
that you can you can aggregate an array
into a structure and pass it into an or
into a UDF and treat it like it's a
table and that'll really what's really
that allows you to do is fork queries so
that you can actually you can take you
can take a stream of data fork the fork
some of the data out and do some really
interesting processing and bring back
the results so all the a great UDF's
follow this pattern the array
aggghhhhh struct construct is really
building up a sub table so that that
creates a struct that creates an array
of a structure and then the EDF you pass
that to UDF and the UDF does some I see
a select statement on it and then passes
the result back here's an example of a
median function written in sequel you'll
notice that the median function takes a
there's an array AG on the numbers that
it's going to collect and then the and
then a none nest of that array really
turns that array back into a table in a
select statement so make sense and I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a demo with with some
interesting UDF's that I've built I'm
starting with the table that really
consists of just five fields it's a a
name a gender a state a year and the
number of people that were born with
that name that gender and that in that
state with in that year okay and so this
is a it's from the Social Security
Administration the data goes from 1910
to 1913 and it's pretty wild what you
can find with just these five fields so
can we switch over to the demo so this
is liquor and that in the IDE I've built
a little model so for each of the
dimensions that are in the table I've
I've created a look ml dimension for the
name state gender year and the number
was a an integer I wanted it as a float
so I cast it I've added a couple of
other measures a decade which is just
divided by ten for the year I've built a
some aggregate and a account and let's
go explore it so this is this is the
liquor a different they look or explore
interface it's pretty simple I can
actually I can start with the total
number and the name count and I can run
that and I can just see how much data
there is it so so there are three
hundred thousand names twenty-nine
thousand different names right I could
add year and look at it by year
let's sort the year and we go to 1930
let's see so done it and then I can see
this shows me the most popular names in
1930 so it's so just building a little
data model all what looker is doing is
that it's writing queries again and
feeding them into sequel so everything
that we click on it really ends up being
just a sequel query now above are the
UDF said I had that I built in for for
this demo but but basically lookers just
write sequel queries against big query
returns the results so you get access to
all the data no matter what you're
looking at so let's see so if I want to
look at the most popular name I can look
at the name and then total number and I
can find the most popular name it's
James John Robert Michael William great
that's that's all terrific I can add
filters let's look at female names and
let's look let's do median year so Mary
the median year for Mary is 1941 the
median year for Patricia's 1940 1951
than the median year for Elizabeth is
1966 now the in this data it's kind of
weird right I just have a state and the
number of people that were born in that
name with that year so what the median
calculation is not simply just just a
simple median it's a weighted median I
have to take a look at that
the median year is that what year were
there's many people born before as after
right and I wanted to build an arrogant
for this which is I want an aggregate
function that does that so I built a
weighted median function and the way to
me that the median year is the median
weighted it passes the year and the
number of people that were born in that
year and I've got a new aggregate that's
in sequel and it so if I actually go
look at the code here it really is quite
quite simple its I use that that that
median weighted median function as if I
as if it were a built in aggregate
function which is really kind of cool
it's actually taking something pretty
complicated and building building me
this new concept of weighted median that
I can use anywhere and let's take a look
at how that function is created so we
have so I built a func this is all open
basically you can all this is open
source so you can grab it and play with
it if you want so there's a weighted
median function here's the here's
basically what it is and it basically
takes an array of it takes in that array
is input does this calculation and
returns the results pretty cool right so
but you can do also other kinds of wild
things too you can do let's let's
actually filter this so it filter this
by state and do look at Alabama come on
versus versus California let's pivot the
state and let's let's look at a graph of
that now again all this is running as a
single sequel query
okay so we can see that Mary in Alabama
the median year for Marion Alabama was
1938 but 1951 we can see a little graph
of what it was and he's kind of
interesting because it was really
popular in 1931 and in in Alabama and it
peaked in 1984 in California so like
maybe it was Annie Hall or something I
don't you know like and it's it's pretty
wild what you can see in the data again
this is just one table with five columns
in it and bigquery on top and some UDF's
it's pretty cool right I think it's cool
and and if you look at the sequel for it
if we if we look at the the definition
for this we can go back and look at the
sorry oh look it back at the sequel here
all the stuff that's doing thing but but
really it's just a time graph UDF and
the time graph takes the data as input
and returns an array of integers which
are the which are the amount for the
decade and then it converts that to a to
an image right so the sequel is just
returning an array of integers all right
and so that's pretty pretty snazzy right
here's another interesting function that
am i doing in time
actually I got another demo but I'm
gonna skip that cuz I want to cook I
look forward can we go back to the so
next thing is the other thing that you
can do with bigquery that's pretty
amazing
so the UDF's are really cool because you
can build these aggregates and do all
kinds of wild stuff with it but nested
nesting is the other thing that is
pretty unusual and bigquery in the end
the scale so very often in big databases
joining two large tables can be a huge
problem right it there are things that
are really hard to do when you have a
couple of large large entities so like
figuring out co-occurrence in large
tables can be very expensive navigating
graphs of data can be very expensive and
a and nesting actually makes a lot of
this stuff better and easier so again if
we if you think about it in a nested
table basically what you have is an
array of structure a record which is
essentially an array of structs that are
stored in the table the example here's
an example of what a nested table looks
like you have a this is an order tables
with order items an order naturally have
if you've got an ecommerce store that
has orders and you can order more than
one thing naturally you'll have an order
in a traditional sequel database you'll
have an orders table and an items table
a line items table or an order in an
order Arkham's table but in essence in a
nested situation what you want is you
can put those in together because they
don't really they don't work without one
another right and then order item really
doesn't exist without an order so that
you can place it in it and as we can see
here the the structure here is an ID
product name quantity and unit price
that's an order item structure and there
and it's repeated within each order so
each of those is like a little sub table
within the order why do you care about
this well first of all fish insec invol
computability if you're trying to figure
out what was bought together you know
very in a really large database you
that's called co-occurrence and you'll
have a really hard time figuring out
basically you can you can join for free
so anytime that you have a nested table
it can be up to a hundred megabytes and
bigquery you can pass that off you can
use the UDF or you can use another
sequel query to process against that or
join against it and it and and that
happens on in a way that is super
efficient there are so I'm really
surprised how fast things work that's
the data that you should look at are
things like orders and order items
sessions and events are really hard so
and one of the traditional things in
sequel is in log data is you have
somebody you session as your data you've
got your event data you roll it up into
a session it's a traditional MapReduce
problem and then you're trying to figure
out who logged in and bought who signed
up today and bought that can be really
tricky in a traditional data warehouse
but it's very cheap to do in an S that
it's in the nested situation because you
can join the data twice and and then and
find co-occurrence other places are user
and asked attributes which you don't
want to nest is something that's not
naturally part of it so like the user is
not really part of an order or an order
items because the user might appear
multiple in multiple different orders so
you wouldn't necessarily table it works
just like it does it like you are
joining another table it looks it looks
complicated but it's actually really
simple let's take a look in this case
I've wait a second sorry I'm missing a
slide I'm sorry this is what an
unnecessary
anyway co-occurrence navigate your graph
navigation super efficient summary
tables that could be larger than a
single row no there's the slide okay
this is I'm sorry it tells you I'm not a
great presenter um anyway so this is how
this is basically what a normal
looks like and this is what an
unnecessary much identical um we had
time it looks like I'm running out of
time so Jordan I'm gonna I'm gonna call
it
sorry I'm just wanted to put it put in a
plug we have a bunch more bigquery
sessions to talk in more more detail
about some of the other the other cool
like beyond data warehousing things like
PQ ml which I'm sure you've heard lots
of lots about today geospatial etc and
the public data sets program as well
tomorrow I also want to say the bigquery
there's a bunch of functional bigquery
team here if you see one over the
bigquery booth in Moscone South please
give us your feedback tell us what you
like what you don't like problems you're
having
etc you know finally I just want to say
you know bigquery is is even better with
looker
I want to thank Lloyd for for being up
here with me and and you know being able
to show what what kind of stuff big
query can do thank you
[Applause]
[Music]